[Music]
i just want to let everybody know okay
there's only 11 tickets left
for sex island 2022. oh man so um
do not miss out well at least there's
six of us
five more gonna
they're about to be [ __ ]
what are the prices for it what's sex
island am i done what do you guys need
what an idiot oh my god
dude leave the room dude
no you got room
island is the premier private event for
sex enthusiasts there's going to be a
hundred hookers
uh you can have unlimited sex with
everyone
july 1st to july 4th three nights four
days for only forty five hundred dollars
so it's a sex buffet did they tell the
hookers about this do they know like
like when you step foot it's 24 hours
seven consent
like you could be sleeping if someone
like slowly wiggles their dick in their
mouth you have to go
down you gotta play ball i'm wondering
three days wait there's hunger sleeping
everywhere yeah yeah they're just
they're mostly sleeping
that's basically what it is it's a it's
a private event where they're only going
to sell 50 tickets that leaves you know
two girls to every uh guest oh you're
allowed to switch you're allowed to
switch girls uh
every day you have to you can you don't
have to you have to
buy amber food
no yeah you can fall in love with them
right
yeah can you can you fall in love with
it and hold on to one for the whole
weekend there's no penalty for your
feels getting in the way at all if i was
a hooker
i want to be the ugliest one there so i
get paid and i don't have to [ __ ] nobody
cause i'll be like the one i'll be the
ugliest one what if it works like champs
something like one out of a hundred we
all get paid the same amount and then we
get there and then
but what if it's performance based for
the hookers oh so it's like the more
guys you [ __ ] the more you you you end
up with a higher paycheck because it's
reasonable they'll be like candy you
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh 50 guys that means you
[ __ ] every single one oh that's pretty
good and then she gets a prize or
something yeah yeah she's on a
leaderboard she gets a new [ __ ] yeah
it's a canoe
stand-up paddleboard
so yeah this is like a casino
it works like this it's only in four
steps that's great it makes it really
easy
pay by wire bank transfer or bitcoin so
you just send them the 4 500 and then i
love this adoption airfare is not
included this happens in uh this happens
in vegas they basically that's not an
island well you arrive there and a
helicopter will take you there to the
island and in the ad it says sexual
helicopter ride whatever that means so
you get a blow job while you're on the
right
you're just watching porno on the
helicopter they have ipads and these hot
girls are holding ipads while you can
watch porn dude can i watch video of
guys going to this instead i just want
to be a fly on the wall i want to see
the 50 dudes and i'll tell you a little
reveal after i show these little
features right here here's the amenities
right there so unlimited sex as you can
see i mean vegas is so good at doing
buffets horseback riding holographic
concert how are you gonna have time to
do all those things
when you're having sex oh look they
covered your meals yeah all the meals
the helicopter service lodging hiv and
std testing so you don't have to use a
condom the whole time you're there wow
what about chlamydia and all the other
stuff or covid come on guys we're
pregnant [ __ ] do they not get
pregnant there yeah this is gender
exclusive only guys can sign up no i
think anybody can go but uh here's the
kicker so they make these trailers like
every year that they do this event don't
tell me it's like the fire fest of sex
it's
even worse than that oh [ __ ] firefighter
oh don't tell me it's the [ __ ] las
vegas police department making this [ __ ]
it's like it's a sting operation
but not vegas not vegas that's why they
got to take you from the helicopter oh
and then they rest to it it takes you to
a private resort somewhere within the in
the nevada desert but uh it's still not
an island here's the kicker it's pretty
much been confirmed that it's just a
giant scam
and that anyone who's ever bought a
ticket has always said that no trip ever
happened what
so they send the money and then it never
happens yeah because they've done this
in trinidad tobago they've done this in
uh colombia they've done it multiple
times and every single time the event
gets cancelled this is too good to be
true this is the big rug pull every time
it's big rug
different kind of rug pull i mean at
least for people who have confirmed
identities who are willing to admit they
bought a ticket oh they got ky most
people are just not going to say
anything they'll be like i don't know
i wouldn't go to sex island personally
but yeah it's one of those things so
just to make sure that this video
doesn't make anybody want to buy a
ticket it's not a real thing yeah not
financial advice yeah nfa and what only
11 slots are available there's always
only 11 slots available like it's like
it's never changing i started looking at
this do they have the ticker on the side
or the thing that shows like three
people are looking at this right now i
like that eight people only two rooms
left who who in our ecosystem do you
think we could send this to and they'd
get they'd fall for it ah a disturbing
amount
i i think yeah or disturbing them i
think a lot of people fall for it
because i mean it is a pretty good deal
4 500 bucks the website looks very
unscammy
and it looks very professional it's a
great website send it to cannes
what like send him the barcode after we
purchased it for him yeah let's buy for
let's buy for a friend there are some
hookers where a warner is like four g's
right here's here's the little trailer
they have for this season that's a good
trailer this is so [ __ ] fake and they
say that like not all the girls in here
are the ones available for prostitution
not sold
not available for prostitution even
these guys they're like those guys
aren't going to sex island bro no it's
not those guys that are buying it it's a
pretty good quality trailer so the thing
is it's put on by a company called good
girls incorporate or something and
that's i think that's like a cam girl
site that sounds legit then good girls
yeah
but
dude but a funny thing is when you're
looking up like the legitimacy of it a
lot of people have uh made complaints
saying that oh like you know i paid this
nothing happened and sex island's
response to that is like oh you guys
were buying from a fake um imposter
yeah like you bought for the wrong
website but how smart would it be to
just be your own imposter and then just
triplicate all your profits from
everybody buying the wrong but i want to
see the guy that's like dude i go every
[ __ ] year it's awesome they're like
they need but that guy's always
anonymous he's just a [ __ ] no no i
want to see a video review yeah cause
he's probably a sex island employee
that's just
freaking impersonating someone can you
go to sex island dressed like a toilet
that is a good question check the uh
faq on that one can you go to sex island
dress like a toilet
by the way it's also drug friendly
they're not gonna you're not gonna get
in trouble for doing any type of drugs
there but they do not provide drugs oh
that's a good quality also here's a
here's a nice one
they end the trailer with the
little bit of confucius don't wait until
you're dead to visit heaven
for when something's a scam
bad
grammar
look at that look at that
look at that i don't see the problem
yeah yeah yeah is that a body that's in
the crack of the sand yeah he died
mountain climber
he got he got the the rare chlamydia my
friend went to something like this in
germany he said that there is like a
sexual buffet all you can eat with a one
price entry fee golden corral
golden horrell no
it's very good he uh he he's uh he does
this uh watch blog
so he he's a part of this yeah so he
just does commentary on watches and all
that stuff
and he got invited by one of the
manufacturers
and he was out there and then um the guy
was just openly like oh yeah you know um
her right there she's like making the
watches
she works at this special uh brothel and
then like he's like what are you talking
about he goes i'll take you and he's
like oh this guy is [ __ ] old and
perverted he's like our age right he's
like in his late 30s and then he went
the guy's like in his late like 50s and
he says like he went in there he [ __ ]
one girl and he was ready to take a nap
but then this old man was like pounding
one after the other and he goes how do
you have a libido of a [ __ ] college
kid dude and then he's like i'm ready to
go he goes that's it you only have sex
with one girl
yeah
and i'm like damn dude you got like
called out a [ __ ] dude he goes i know
but i come fast these days these days
i come fast these years
these days and i'm like that's just
crazy uh it's legal and it exists and i
it's prostitution is legal in um germany
oh in all of germany holy [ __ ] yeah it's
i mean it's like i guess oh is it like
decriminalized kind of legal you mean
yeah like regulated and [ __ ] yeah but he
was like they have a whole place
where you stay
like not sleep over but like it's like
it's got multiple rooms it's got like
food entertainment things and he goes
like you just chill take a break
and then you just keep going all right
who here is [ __ ] the hooker [ __ ] man i
know a lot of people that has
i know a lot of people that has i know a
guy who eats a hooker's [ __ ] sometimes
but i know dude that's about it that guy
sounds like a [ __ ] gem that sounds
familiar that sounds like a legend
whoever does that i think that guy's
very thoughtful and i think he's a very
caring person yeah i think is he here
why do you guys say like he's in this
room yeah
he's in this room legend
sometimes when you haven't had sex for a
long time and you get super horny you
just want to give you know
that is salvation army i still don't
know which guy it is i don't know he's a
giver dude okay joe should get a
thousand dollars taken off the sex
island it depends on how
cause i'm a giver so one of the things
that makes uh sex island kind of not
seem legit is that it's hard to put on
an event like this in terms of what the
local government would allow like
there's no permit for something like
that because even in colombia when they
tried to do it in colombia even though
like prostitution is not
illegal pimping still is
and the format in which they're doing
this would be considered pimping oh i
thought it was going to be like a
consent issue because like let's say you
have fight island right and technically
everyone everyone's down to fight on
that island
but but you can't just go up to someone
and just punch them in the face still
because that would be assault right it
needs to be original fight i'm down to
fight okay let's fight so so i'm like uh
with sex and i'm still assuming you
can't just start like poking your dick
in people's eyes and [ __ ] yeah maybe
there's like a code of conduct that they
teach you isn't it just like um like a
secret handshake or you're like it's
like a strip club where you don't have
to pay for lap dances where the girls
are walking around and sets right and
just kind of like you and they're going
to come over because that's like what
they're getting paid you can't just grab
her titty you got to like yeah but you
know like the second you make that
connection it's kind of like hey can i
you know what i mean there maybe they're
they're
maybe if it is commission based like a
lab dance it's not like you're paying
them direct because you've already paid
to enter the place yeah maybe they first
hang out with you because they're trying
to get your
connection yeah and then from there
after you're done they like get another
point on the leaderboard if anybody can
pull off sex island it's anthony lee
yeah i don't know why he put that much
thought into it i just do pr i just do
pr you're the bachelor personal rights
you're trying to make this business work
like three of them i like fight island
you find out it's not like mortal kombat
yeah and maybe it's really just as
simple as mortal kombat some guys are
just playing the drums and everyone
knows it's time to go all right this is
the ceremony
kicking each other's asses
and you bought tickets to that you're
paying five grand a [ __ ] fight that's
breaking they're eating and they hear
their drums no time to fight guys dude
you're at the buffet and you're some guy
punches you in the face
that's basically that's basically the
enter the dragon island
yeah yeah
i like this it says is sex island real i
don't like they already know there's
gonna be like ins that's the first thing
you see and then it scrolls down and
says yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you